The Add to Home Screen for
Mobile Safari is a little different, but
it allows you to do many of the same
things that the web app manifest does.
Instead of putting everything in
the manifest, Safari looks for
a set of meta tags in the document head.
Let's start with the icons.
The easiest thing to do is
place an apple-touch-icon.png
document in the folder.
But if you want to specify icons for
different device resolutions,
you'll need to add
a link rel apple touch
icon with a sizes attribute for
each image.
To cover all of the current devices,
you'll need six icon sizes.
60 pixels, 76 pixels, 120 pixels,
152, 167 and 180 x180.
To hide the browser UI components,
add an apple mobileweb
app capable content equals
yes attribute to the head,
which will start the app
without any browser UI.
If you want to minimize the status bar,
you can add in apple mobile web app
status bar style meta tag to the head.
If you do that,
remember to add some padding as
the status text is still there.
Check the instructor notes below for
links to the latest documentation from
Apple on Configuring Web Applications
and some of the finer details.